>> I WILL BE GONE, I GUESS.
THERE IS A TEACHER SHORTAGE, SO
I WILL FIND SOMEWHERE TO TO DO
THE SAME THING.
>> JOINING ME AS MATT WALSH,
HOST OF THE MATT WALSH'S SHOW.
THEY ARE THROWING IT IN OUR
FACE, IS THAT HOW YOU FEEL?
>> ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU SEE HOW
THEY ARE DRESSED AND HOW THEY
LOOK.
THE TEACHERS LOOK LIKE LIBRARIAN
BUT NOW THEY LOOK LIKE DRUG
ADDICTS AND CARNIES.
WHICH IS A TOTAL MORAL ANARCHY
IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
ALSO THE FACT IT IS OVERRUN BY
THE LEFTIST RADICALS BECAUSE
GUESS WHAT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL
THE STUFF HAPPENING ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND THE CRAZY MARXIST
STUDENTS AND EVERYTHING TO
CONSOLE OURSELVES AND SAY, GIVE
IT TO THE REAL WORLD AND THEY
WILL CHANGE.
NO, THEY CAME TO THE REAL WORLD
AND BECAME TEACHERS.
AND THIS IS WHAT WE END UP WITH.
>> Jesse: THEY PUT IT OUT ALL
OVER SOCIAL MEDIA, THOSE
CRIMINALS THAT COMMIT CRIMES AND
TAKE PICTURES OF THEMSELVES WITH
THE STOLEN MERCHANDISE AND PUT
IT ON INSTAGRAM.
DO YOU WORRY THAT THE COUNTRY IS
SO FOCUSED ON UKRAINE THAT THE
LEFT IS DOING STUFF BEHIND OUR
BACK?
I JUST SAW THE OTHER DAY THAT
THEY JUST ANNOUNCED BIDEN
SHATTERED MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION RECORDS.
LIKE HE DOESN'T SUPPORT ANYBODY.
NOBODY HAS BEEN DEPORTED AND HE
HAS NOT MADE ANY ARRESTS.
I WORRY ABOUT THAT.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT THAT?
>> I CERTAINLY DO WORRY ABOUT
IT.
OF COURSE, THINGS HAPPENING
AROUND THE WORLD ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT AND ALL OF
THAT, BUT THIS IS STUFF THAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM, WE HAVE
50 MILLION KIDS THAT GO EVERYDAY
IN THESE INDOCTRINATION CAMS,
NOT JUST PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT
PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE IN A MUCH
BETTER.
YOU MAY BE WORRIED WHAT IS
HAPPENING OVERSEAS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES, BUT THIS IS HAPPENING
IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
THE KIDS ARE BEING SUBJECTED TO
THIS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
FOR THAT, IMAGINE SITTING IN A
CLASSROOM WITH SOMEBODY LIKE
THAT EVERY SINGLE DAY SEVEN
HOURS A DAY, FIVE DAYS A WEEK
FOR SO MAN